pour ce premier week-end de confinement
les yvelinois ont décidé de sortir pour
faire du sport tout en respectant le
rayon des 10 km imposées par les
autorités
un plaisir une partie de pétanque
s'organisant le parc d'autres n'ont pas
hésité à enfourcher leur bicyclette à la
je veux faire du vélo la du vélo tout le
long du parc là et puis j'ai peut-être
m'arrêter un petit peu voilà prendre un
peu le soleil a vu qu'il est encore là
voilà profiter un petit peu ça va faire
du bien
j'ai besoin de verdure des espaces de me
balader du sport également à voisins le
bretonneux ce dimanche matin des enfants
font du roller dans cette aire de jeu
ici à 50 mètres cette famille joue au
rugby sur l'herbe depuis plus d'une
heure
sinon resteraient entre quatre murs dans
le salon on aurait un peu en rond dont
corinne on sait très bien de pouvoir
s'aérer en plus ce n'est pas même pas
mal d'espacés verts autour de la maison
on en profite ici ça va ça fait du bien
ça fait beaucoup de bien mais ne touche
pas le collège malgré le confinement
ouais ça fait du bien en ce qui concerne
le sport encadré en extérieur les
structures ouvertes à la pratique ont
accueilli presque autant de public que
d'habitude au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le parking est
plein ce dimanche plus de 250 golfeurs
sont présents sur le site
un chiffre élevé pour la saison ce
week-end voilà il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de joueurs de la région des dix
kilomètres qui viennent jouer ici ça
peut permettre à des gens aux alentours
qui avait l'habitude de jouer sur
d'autres parcours de venir jouer au golf
national et de découvrir nos parcours
ce nouveau confinement devrait durer au
minimum pendant quatre semaines